What are some things that you have never done in your entire life?
For example, I'll tell you what mine is.
My family motto is "Don't lie, be honest",...
...so, all my life I have tried not to lie in any case.
What's a family motto?
I've heard about a company motto, or a program motto,...
...but never about a "family motto".
Is that something like precepts?
Yes, what could be the best way to say this?
It provides family members with the guidelines and precepts for behavior.
You know, Korean families regard a family bond as very important.
We all think what we do and how we behave represents the whole family,...
...so it is very important to set a rule or motto...
...and keep the behavior to remind family members to behave accordingly.
Some families have their mottos passed down from their ancestors,...
...and some make up their own.
Is there such a thing in your country, or any other western society?
Like you said, I think mottos are related to a collective society.
Most western countries including where I am from, focus on individual behavior.
In other words, a person stands out for himself.
Others don't link him or her with their other family members.
But if I were to have a family motto,...
...I would choose something like "Do your best or try your hardest."